[Music]
in
celebrity fight news oh
all right
bart and i are fighting each other next
week
are we doing the pacquiao no no but this
dude about jake paul and tommy fury
again
it's back on now
back on it is back on however
uh most recently actually jake paul was
uh obviously talking more [ __ ] on tommy
fury cause tommy's trying to pull out
cause apparently he was why it's about
his father i think well he was saying so
i saw that jake video and uh jake's
really good at marketing fights and
talking [ __ ] but he's pretty much saying
hey guys all of you guys are like buying
into this pay-per-view tommy's trying to
pull out again he's saying how like he
can't get his team into the states uh he
can't get his dad or whatever into the
states and he's like but bro we all know
your dad's a known criminal he couldn't
come in the states for a long time and
he still did the other fight and he said
if you can't get your team in i'll fight
you without my team just two people
let's make the fight happen
uh that was the last video i saw i think
maybe yesterday and literally today he
goes that [ __ ] has tommy is down to
fight now i guess he grew a sack or
something overnight
yeah whoa
instigating yeah bart got exactly right
he said all that stuff he also said
stuff like um is there pre-sales he
probably sent him the pre-sale so that's
probably what happened
jake was talking about how their team
had like uh complied to like all the
writer requirements for tommy fury
everything from like you know needing
this needing that you know tickets for
this yeah flights and stuff getting your
[ __ ] extra guests into the fight like
we [ __ ] signed everything um but
same thing he's just saying how like
without his father in the corner but no
criminal is he ducking still so tommy
fury responds on twitter to jake's video
and says quote the fight is on august 6
forget a team or any other [ __ ] i
don't need anybody to help me lay you
flat on that canvas oh and thanks for
finally signing the drug testing you
only agreed to it when you realized the
fight was at risk who needs who oh
so that was that was probably pulled out
before
just the first time first time right now
but that was like fractured ribs or
something like that right what wait are
they fighting in a real weight class
like what are they doing yeah they're
fighting msg isn't that crazy what
really what that's what i heard holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's probably gonna pull the
numbers wait have they have they been
fighting without headgear yeah these are
like these are awesome
this is a pro fight but
i mean he hasn't fought a boxer is this
one tommy fury would be considered his
first box yeah but why is tommy tommy
actually feels threatened to pull out a
fight because they're brilliant dude i
think well look bro at this point it's
like
they're walking into a fight
jake paul
has shown that he can knock people out
that's power which is kind of crazy and
whether you think you can beat this guy
or not
as a fighter you always have the back of
your head like dude this guy if i lose
to this [ __ ] guy well here's the
thing he's like he has everything to
gain yeah
jake paul nothing to lose because if he
loses he'll just be like yeah he lost a
boxer yeah and if tommy fury wins
it's like yo you were supposed to your
box or your tummy but you will have the
support of everybody and because so many
people want to see potential and he'll
get a two million dollar purse or
something yeah for sure really yeah for
tommy but the same time it's like these
[ __ ] are probably thinking more
about the other ramifications like what
if i become a meme or some [ __ ] you will
become one it's going to require it's
requires someone of extreme focus
and discipline
to come in and block out the noise the
mind games the mind games because that's
what he's excellent at right so good
he's going to come in he's going to play
mind games till the last [ __ ] till he
walks into the ring i'm sure he's taking
his training seriously but fighting a
lifetime of boxers as a professional
boxer and being like i just you know i
train with a bunch of people i mean i'm
sure he's doing the right things and
eating correctly but like
experience
when you're in the ring you're in the
ring i think jay says he wants to be the
light heavyweight champion of the world
so then he should probably start
boxing boxers yeah he's putting uh he's
putting crazy statements out there
causing a lot of noise and i think
i don't i don't know if he's like
strategizing this consciously but i
think he's creating noise and almost
securing the destination while he does
all his weird like retired people fights
but eventually leveling up to the point
where he can be a contender he's right
he's kind of genius well for him it's i
think it's just a great way to market
himself and make money yeah i saw the
poster and it's like these guys want to
fight them they're agreeing to it it's
not like they're you know they're being
forced yeah i saw the poster and it says
jake paul 5-0 and i'm like holy [ __ ]
it's been five fights already yeah
crazy right
five pro fights already in the one
aspirin got knocked out
uh
twice twice are they counting that one
fight with the youtuber
gabe is the first got them out twice
yeah yeah and you beat him well tyler
wooley two was because tyson fury pulled
out so he came in last second but he
didn't get knocked out the first time no
the first one was the decision was
actually so crazy but that's crazy oh he
lost the decision you know woodley do
you think all this [ __ ] is wrong
boxer no of course but at the same time
it's like well as you're watching this
fight and like you know you're watching
i'm telling you and me that someone
who's talking about be like we're gonna
wrestle yeah you're gonna smash me no
nine times out of like ten out of ten
yeah no but at the same time it's like
you would think like watching like when
you watch jake paul box in that fight
with tyron woodley in the first one
you're like man there's so many like
holes that you would imagine
a guy like tyrone woodley even though
he's not the best boxer and not a very
good striker and he's also one of the
best combat athletes yeah but it's
different dude mma is like it's
different well of course what i'm saying
even with his striking ability that
tyron woodley has which is limited in a
boxing
practice you would think man these are
still basic principles that i feel that
with your level of ability you could
take advantage professionally on a guy
like jake paul but i don't think he
trained seriously for these things no i
don't think so either everyone
underestimates because they go oh it's a
[ __ ] youtuber [ __ ] this guy
i think
jake is putting two hundred percent
effort 100 percent and these are
opportunities
all of his opponents are just taking it
easy and which is why i think now
there's gonna be a shift yeah i mean if
they're fighting in msg he fury better
[ __ ] take this seriously oh i think
he i think he is but then again
well this is like fury's biggest fight
now technically yeah it is and it's jake
paul but at the same time it's like easy
if you go into tommy fury's uh this is
crazy that i'm even saying this but if
you go into tommy fury's past fights
jake paul is probably going to be one of
the tougher guys he's going to fight
like it is crazy see i don't know enough
because the thing about boxing in
general like because what tommy fury's
what 8-0 yeah right they have a crazy
record yeah they have a tendency of when
you first get your like first 15 to even
20 fights
you might be fighting guys who are not
that good a lot of bumps yeah it's
because you want to build because that's
part of the culture and boxing they got
built up yeah he's already got a name
for eight fights what's up he's already
got a name from because he's a tyson
fury's brother well that's the main
thing oh
the fact of that jake paul's been
calling him out so there's a lot of like
this
this and he looks sexy he's in the media
yeah his arms literally touch his
[ __ ] knees bro he's definitely sexier
than his brother
his half brother or whatever but yeah so
it's really interesting to see how this
is all gonna play out because
there's a good chance that tommy fury
might lose there's a good chance who are
you putting money on
i don't know bro putting money on it i
don't know who's we but joe putting
money can you check what your dogs are
who's going to check the odds if the
underdog should we go
i'm betting just fall yeah
because bro because that's my job no no
but
your job's a bet against us no my job is
to get the underdogs i don't hate
because the reality is he's gonna go in
the ring and we're gonna see the results
i just want both opponents to take it
seriously yeah and i think these guys
are i want to see a good fight but then
again no matter what any guy any guy
that's going to fight jake paul who has
a little bit more experience you're
always going to say that [ __ ]
didn't take it seriously like
unfortunately jake is you
you take a serious you don't know what
i'm i'm talking about what the people
are going to say but at the same time it
takes away from jake paul i think yeah
like people want to discredit him more
because he is an [ __ ] like people
don't like his weapon i think that'll
disappear if he starts fighting boxers
who are not retired this is his first
chance like you know what i mean this is
his first one so people will still say
it at 25 and no
yeah but like it's a youtuber say jake
paul [ __ ] shows a beautiful boxing
skill and [ __ ] beats the [ __ ] out
tommy fury people are always going to be
like well tommy fury wasn't even that
good
but then yeah but then jake's got to
bring on the next one
if he if this is what he wants to do he
wants to be the light heavyweight he
who's the light heavyweight champion
right now [ __ ] b-ball
the guy who just beat canelo right yeah
yeah
so he he he's gonna have to box canelo
one day yeah exactly and he's he's
already calling out he's been talking
[ __ ] he's gonna beat canelo hell no that
was actually crazy canelo will kill him
because by the time though by the time
he gets there do you feel like canelo he
might be like what fight
he might be like going down as he's
coming it's playing a smart game that's
probably no part of it so so odds it
says that tommy fury is minus 200
favored to win at 66.67 percent that's
and jake paul's odds are plus 150 at 40
percent change plus 150
plus
thank you sports betting is legal in new
york let's go i already live in vegas
who are you betting on joe what do you
think underdogs that's the that's the
thing every every single time you watch
a fight should we do it yeah come on
down all right so you're going to go
underdog well bet time fury
i'm always betting underdog because
that's the thing everyone here bets the
for sure bet and i bet opposite this
fight's in august august 6th
well we've only had one case study so i
don't know we are breaking tradition
oh no it's saturday uh usually it's we
bet who we want and then you just go
against it no i want to bet the underdog
i bet the home town last time because it
was a hometown not because of odds no i
went the underdog because you guys bet
homecoming but also yeah we chose the
hometown steve was like oh rams are
probably gonna win that's what his
analysis was and we're from l.a you know
you gotta vote for your hometown okay
we'll see you i didn't i went underdogs
you're more than welcome to bet for the
underdog i don't want to always bet the
other way then i'll always lose i want
to bet the underdog every single time so
then i have a chance to win they're all
betting together this time
plus now we have the bet together
because he has to win big if he actually
wins and then watch we all lose
it becomes a giraffe [ __ ] what's going
on
after jake paul's fight with tyler
woodley so i know someone's pretty close
to tyrone woodley
[Laughter]
i just couldn't believe it so i texted
him and he goes honestly tyron put
everything in into training like he's
very he has a huge ego in a good way i
don't know dude didn't look like that
but he only had three like two weeks
though but he like
oh tyrone isn't someone never
yeah like he's someone that's like
really serious about his [ __ ] i'm like
damn that's crazy he almost knocked him
out in the first fight i'm like man yeah
i saw that what what happened that he
just like but this is like what do you
think even watching him mma
if tyrone woodley doesn't knock you out
in the first round with a big blitz and
a big
uh flurry
nothing happens afterwards like he has
incredibly low striking volume so in a
fight he's he's way less likely to throw
more strikes the more strikes you throw
the more likely it's to land yeah and he
lowers that signif that percentage
significantly because he doesn't throw
enough and that's what happened to jake
paul fight he heard him and he was like
waiting for the big shot waiting for the
big shot but if you're trying to set up
a big shot without do throwing anything
else beforehand it's gonna be really
hard to land that shot and that's what i
think happened in that fight
in the first one you guys heard about
how like uh mayweather still hasn't paid
his brother dude yeah but also hey today
logan paul there's news that conor
mcgregor wants to fight floyd mayweather
again i saw that what yeah crazy
crazy this is one of the money grabs
yeah these big money fights he probably
needs another yacht connor needs more
money for his cocaine dude his yacht
what about our boy pacquiao fighting our
favorite artist dku i bought his course
dku's heating course
what sucks
pacquiao i think he's such a nice guy
that's gonna be nice if it's an
exhibition fight i think he'll just
dance he's gonna really do this but i
want to actually dance like they're
going to samba with each other i want to
see i want to see like somebody die
yeah you see someone die yeah
i i can't imagine how that fight's gonna
be pacquiao mayweather fight was pretty
fun but then pacquiao looked injured as
[ __ ] yeah he hit his head towards labrum
his shoulder yeah wasn't something wrong
with his leg or foot too yeah but yeah
he wasn't a hundred percent he wasn't a
speed yeah i was also [ __ ] 10 years
later you know i don't know much about
the whole mayweather stuff but wasn't he
wasn't his strategy also like that
people give him flack for not fighting
people in his prime or in their prime
that that's the beauty of it right like
he controls everything yeah yeah he's
smart set things up but even then it's
like
he's such a good [ __ ] box like yeah
he's so good he's just so [ __ ] he
makes canelo look like he sucks yeah
yeah but that was way before his crime
that was way before clinic on canelo
yeah
but hey it's floyd mayweather and he's
probably gonna knock out conor mcgregor
again because conor mcgregor only wants
to drink you know whiskey and do coke
drop a number 12. that sounds sick
and buy yachts and buy lamborghini
yachts dude
you